what do you make of this news with
regard to Teamsters and potentially uber
drivers forming a union well look I
think that this is sort of an emerging
market space and there's a natural
give-and-take
I think the announcement today the
settlement is a win-win I think it's a
good step in the right direction
I think it's uber saying we're gonna be
doing more to sort of self-regulate but
I do think that the market has some fits
and starts here but I see this as an
overall win for uber now uber and the
CEO Travis kalanick have emphasized they
believe drivers value independence value
their flexibility despite the this
class-action lawsuit however a lawyer
for the driver said today no court no
court has decided here whether Ober
drivers are employees or independent
contractors and that debate will not end
here this case stands as a stern warning
to companies who play fast and loose
with classifying their workforce as
independent contractors who do not
receive the benefits of the wage laws
and other employee protections so of
course they've just settled this but
again no court has actually made a
decision here professor you know what do
you think of the broader implications
for the sharing economy and for uber
going forward well as far as uber is
concerned this is a big win for them as
you've pointed out Uber's biggest source
of valuation risk is uncertainty around
worker classification this is a big step
in the direction of uber being able to
sort of like you know put that issue
aside and as a consequence I think that
the hundred million dollars they're
going to make up sort of multifold
through an increase in the evaluation I
think overall this is good for the
sharing economy I'm sure that there are
situations in which it makes sense to
classify sharing economy providers as
employees but with uber drivers and lyft
drivers I don't think this is one of
those cases I do think however it's
really important that we start to think
about a way in which we can fund
benefits for these drivers and for other
providers in the sharing economy
it's not going to come all from uber
it's not all going to come from the
government it's not going to come from
the drivers themselves there has to be a
partnership model and you know I think
when we look back on this case
we're not going to remember the details
of the settlement but we're going to see
it as the event that triggered this
conversation about the need to protect
the workforce of the future which is
going to be largely freelance now one of
the interesting parts of this settlement
is that drivers can now say hey tips
aren't required or expected but they are
very much appreciated and one of the
great things about the uber experience
has been to press a button get in get
out and not have to worry about a tip or
worry about doing anything else you Paul
what do you make of that could that
significantly change the uber experience
so I think people have a newly ingrained
habit of just uber a ride they like the
idea that it just sort of shows up like
a teleporter you know whenever they they
hit this they're out of the app on their
phone but at the same time you know that
is not an insignificant issue you know I
liked it you liked it we all liked the
idea that it took away this kind of end
of ride decision-making about what I
have to do with respect to a tip which
sounds silly but it was really important
and now the problem is is having
reinstituted that at the back end what
happens if I don't tip does that mean
that I as a passenger get a bad rating
and that the next time I call for an
uber an uber doesn't come and get me
because I didn't tip last time it
introduces a weird new source of
uncertainty because you sort of backdoor
reintroducing this thing that we thought
we got rid of which was this nasty sort
of subjective business of tipping and
cab rides now rashon you know what have
you heard from drivers about do they do
they want tips do they do they even want
to put the cells out there like that
am I talking to drivers and I've talked
to a couple I think everybody's happy to
get tips obviously it's a great extra
source of income and it sort of shows
the recognition and appreciation for the
work that they're doing I do think that
uber is going to over and lyft and
others will probably have to sort of
integrate or iterate their product in
order to accommodate that and how they
choose to do it whether it's at the
point where you leave the car or the
point where the the receipt comes back
and you can see the total
that remains to be seen but I'm sure
drivers will be happy to have tips
included or added now it's clear that
laws still need to change in order to
accommodate the sharing economy so Arun
what are some of the hurdles going
forward for uber and other sharing
economy companies well I think what's
really going to create an opportunity
for uber for lyft for the other sharing
economy platforms is if we successfully
create a safe harbor in which they can
demonstrate that they are willing to
participate in sort of providing a
safety net for their drivers if there
isn't the threat of this kind of you
know sort of class-action lawsuit and so
I don't see the case as having
eliminated the threat of like you know
sort of you know additional costs that
may come from different worker
classification but I do see it as laying
the foundations for being able to say
that now let's go ahead let's create the
safe harbor and let us show you that
like you know we are willing to sort of
pay for part of the benefits that these
drivers the face of our brands the
providers who were sort of fighting with
each other to retain to bring to our
platform give us the space to be able to
sort of offer them different things that
they want as a retention strategy and so
you know I mean companies have done this
all the time with employees and so it's
important that we sort of create a space
for the sharing economy platforms to be
able to sort of do the same kinds of
things